تشرع الحكومه الفرنسيه في وضع اهليه جديده
لمساعده بعض الفئات على مواجهه ارتفاع
اسعار الوقود
فان حوالي 10 ملايين فرنسي بامكارهم
الاستفاده من مبلغ 100
€ وسيكون على الاشخاص الذين يحق لهم
الاستفاده تعبئه قسيمه في موقع خاص في
بمصحه الضرائب بدا من اليوم وحتى نهايه
الشهر المقبل
الجزيره نور الدين هذه المساعدات الى اي
مدى يتوقع ان تخفف من تضرر هذه الفئات من
ازمه الوقت واسعارها
مريم دعيني اولنا نرجع الى خلفيه هذا
القرار تذكرين جيدا عندما بدات حرب
اوكرانيا كيف ارتفعت اسعار الطاقه وقت اذا
الحكومه بدات تتخوف من رده فعل الشارع
الفرنسي وفعلا ظهرت مظاهرات او خرجت
مظاهرات تطالب الحكومه بتخفيض اسعار
الوقود وتحدث الكثيرون عن ان التضخم في
فرنسا لم يعد يطاق وقت اذ ماذا قررت
الحكومه مريم قررت مثلا ان تفرض على مثل
هذه المحطات وشركات النفط ان يخفف ويقلل
الاسعار بنسبه 40 سم في البدايه حتى شهر
همم
اغسطس الماضي ثم بعد ذلك من اغسطس حتى
نهايه هذه السنه حتى 31 من ديسمبر طلب
منهم تخفيض بنسبه 10 سنه الان وقد استقرت
الاسعار وان ساحه التعبير قال الى حد ما
قلت الاضطرابات باسعار الوقود عالميا ماذا
تريد الحكومه تريد الحكومه ان لا تدفع له
مثل هذه المحطات وللشركات التكرير
المساعدات التي كانت دفعتها وبلغت سبعه
ملايير يورو وتريد ان تعود ذلك بدفع ما
يقارب 100 يورو للعائله التي لا تستطيع او
للعائلات التي تستخدم السيارات باتجاه
العمل والعوده من العمل الى البيت هذه
المساعدات لا يبدا العمل بها الا نهايه
فبراير الان هذا الاجراء لماذا لان
الحكومه الان على مرحله صعبه جدا وهي
التضخم والمظاهرات وخاصه معارضه ما يسمى
بمشروع اصلاح التقاعد تريد ان تمتص هذا
الغضب من خلال هذه الاجراءات المشكله
والمفارقه مريم ان لبعض ينتقد هذه الاجراء
ويقول بانه سيساعد اولا بعض الناس وليس كل
الفرنسيه